thanks Peter said Elias color is meant
to be an institutional repository of
sorts it's been in I guess what I would
call a quiet launch phase for about six
months while we started to accumulate
some content and I'm not going to do a
presentation so much is a very rapid to
demo some of its features because if you
know where it is it is live first thing
to know is what is the secret URL which
is not very secret Eli scholar library
yale edu always loved doing something
live a new computer yeah it's there well
it's mostly there no there we go okay as
I said it's been it's been in a soft
rollout phase for about the six last six
months fairly soon we're going to be
going public with it with a link on them
on the main library website I think some
special thanks are in order to Kelly
Barakat csss I and Charlie Greenberg at
Medical who among others have been
uploading quite a bit of content as well
as helping some people upload their own
eli scholar has two main functions as I
see it one is as a publishing platform
suitable for publishing out of print
content as well as managing new content
such as journals and theses including
some workflow and editorial controls
secondly is a self publishing platform
for faculty staff and graduate students
who would like to have a simple way of
creating their own portfolio page and
highlighting their own work in terms of
who uses it there's a large group of
people using the be pressed platform
among our peers pen has has a large
repository and more locally the Yale
School of Law has had their own version
of it up running for a number of years
now and have had in the millions of
downloads so once you get a critical
mass of content into a platform like
this people really do come to it and
seek you out and putting us in in I
guess in a slightly larger context since
Peter was talking about some of the
functions of libraries in the digital
age in terms of bringing digital
resources and print resources together
and creating a place where content is
created this is a place to do something
with that
and libraries have traditionally brought
content from other places and provided
it to the students and scholars but what
happens to that student and scholar
content well I gets published in a
variety of journals and time sometimes
you can find it that way it's not always
easy to find it in one place and
particularly on the student side unless
it's a dissertation and ends up then the
well-known dissertation database at
ProQuest which we all know defined if we
are in the library or an academic
institution that has access to it it's
pretty hard to find the rest of that
student work and there's an awful lot of
really good student work being done
that's not necessarily at the phd level
so this is an opportunity to for easily
publishing student-run journals student
essay contests any academic department
that decided to want to put honors
theses in and it's great for materials
like that so now I just want to quickly
run through some examples of some of the
content that I think are good some
examples of out of print content well
we'll click on this one since it's
running through the slideshow anyway
here we have the Nepal Studies
Association newsletter which marked
orange we'll be hearing from in a bit
helped me upload so this is a newsletter
dating from 19 dating to 1972 it's been
out of print we have uploaded all of
those out of print issues they're here
as PDFs they're easy to find and we've
got a link to what it morphed into which
which is the Himalayan research bulletin
which we don't host but someone else
does but you can link to it from here
and find it one more example here i'll
just i'll go but go to the Browse view
yale medical theses we have a lot of eel
medical theses many of them have now
been entered in here so we have these
seasoned dissertations from 1952 to 1992
there are a lot more that are going in
but the point is these can now be found
they've existed in print they've existed
in a rather hard to find digital system
at the Yale School of Medicine library
but now we're getting into get them into
a system that is crawled by Google which
I'll talk about in a moment and is
associated with other Yale content so
again out of print content being made
accessible we also have things that are
existing in print
but it's nice to have a digital version
as well the Yale School of Nursing
alumni newsletters has a nice series
2003 going back 1999 2002 and on again
we got the nice print cover here you can
see what the print edition looks like
but you can also download it and see a
digital version another type of content
this is very useful for is conferences
we have one conference up y el de of
data you can see information about the
conference you can actually browse the
conference you can see who's
participating in the conference you can
see the schedule of events for the
conference if you want to see one of
these nice schedules you can also see
the poster submissions and you can
submit posters this actually takes you
to where you can submit a poster so if
you're planning a conference you could
manage the submission process and then
you can also go straight to the poster
itself I haven't clicked on this one but
hopefully it works so here we have
metadata about the poster who created
the poster energy click over here you
can download the poster journal of do
because it might take a little more time
than i want to spend right now trying to
be quick here so that's an example not
only of content being presented and
managed but managing the production of
content that's something that if we
tried to build ourselves will be rather
difficult which is one reason we went
with a solution like digital Commons 4b
press because the workflows are built in
we have several early adopter ejournal
candidates that we're working with now
so we'll be bringing some journals
online where they will be using the
whole workflow process or the Editorial
Board of the journal gets trained they
can solicit submissions manage
submissions manage the peer review
process and then publish the electronic
journal they can also do a print journal
at the same time if they like but this
manages the whole process soup to nuts
second big piece that we have which we
have not done much to publicize yet is
the portfolio piece which they call
selected works and if you look in here
you will see that we have some
enterprising people who already have
selected works pages some of these
existed before we
signed up for a Yale subscription
because you can create your own on the B
press site but if your email address
happens to be led you now that we have a
license you get a a branded version of
your page what that also means is if you
have a paging you leave Yale you take it
with you it's portable it's not a
portfolio that only lasts while you're
here which is why we think it might be
nice for graduate students if you want
to start rolling it out for them just a
moment just to go to a random example
actually the first example this is
someone who had a pre-existing site
apparently when we turned it on boom you
got populated into the into the Yale
site and mr. Ayers has a lot the ratings
on here you've got them organized in his
own way there's an antitrust writing
civil rights writings contracts
corporations and cheerful popular press
the faculty member or student our staff
has control over what categories they
want to organize their work in typically
this is used for preprints and post
prints but you can put anything you want
in here assuming you have the rights to
it and we have some verbiage on the site
about you know I really should know what
you're putting up and have to have a
copy right to it you can put a profile
picture up you can put a join my mailing
list follow me as you get you know they
automatically notified when something
you gets added to my page you can put
your own links in here he has some
websites that he decided to link to and
perhaps most importantly if you have one
of these pages you get statistics sent
to you I think how many downloads are
you getting is downloading your work
which is very nice thing to have which
gets me to the last thing I wanted to
mention statistics are great if you have
a series in here you're the series owner
you get statistics on who's been
downloading things from your series
whether it's a journal or a collection
of papers or whatever is you're an
individual author you get statistics on
how many of your copies have been
downloaded and looked at but one of the
nice things about this is it's all
extremely searchable I ran a few random
Google searches this morning go to try
one again or two here just to show you
how it works let's pick up something
like this is when the medical theses
library follicular lymphoma now if I did
that just by itself i would get
thousands and thousands of Google hits
but if I happen to know that somebody
did something at Yale about it and
trifle
lymphoma Yale there it is it's the fifth
item down here is night up in our
repository showing up on google and
there's the little cover page it
generates and it takes you right into
their medical thesis another quick
example let's try that Nepal newsletter
once again I will put in Yale because I
tried doing just Nepali newsletter and
there are literally dozens and dozens
and dozens of Nepal newsletters that
show up but if you happen to know yell
might have something to do with it it
shows up number one and two and three
and four it's really well with the
sometimes you'll get the main issue page
I'm gonna get individual issues you get
multiple hits but the point is these
things get ranked very high in google
searches if you have any kind of keyword
search that's close to something that's
in here and particularly happen its
associated with Yale and add Yale as a
keyword it's going to take you right to
the collection often right to a
particular work within a collection that
you're interested in I'll do one more
just because this is the newest the
newest bit of content they got uploaded
Cole Porter critical edition Kiss Me
Kate let's see if those will work
without adding Yale
might see mmm didn't quite make it into
the top page it did when I did it
earlier we'll try adding al to that
there it is number two so music library
has just added the critical edition
notes to kiss me kate it's a very large
PDF file so I won't try to click on it
and download it but the the cold 40
people who created the print version of
critical Edition are very happy about
this addition to it so that's a very
quick overview of what Eli scholar can
do and some of the kinds of materials we
can put in it and I've got a few minutes
left for questions right thank you very
much Michael